artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence jobs artificial
intelligence you've heard the AI
warnings every technological Revolution
affects the job market AI could cause
some humans their jobs in the near
future but AI is also creating some new
jobs specifically one so I decided to
apply job title prompt engineer
responsibilities writing text commands
or prompts to get the best answers out
of a generative AI large language model
like chat BT pay up to
$250,000 a year to figure out exactly
what a prompt engineer does I decided to
apply to B1 at heia a new york-based AI
startup wish me
luck hi good to meet you nice to meet
you I have wanted to be a prompt
engineer since I as long as I can
remember all right fine the company was
in on this little experiment it's really
interesting that you say that that
because the role actually didn't exist
until maybe a year ago yes prompt
engineering is a totally new type of job
because well large language models or
llms like chat GPT only hit the scene a
year ago and if you've used chat GPT
prompt engineering is actually pretty
easy to understand you type in your
prompt instructing whatever you'd like
the large language model to do the model
then returns an answer but sometimes
that answer is unwieldy or not what you
wanted the better the input the better
the output for really one of the first
times ever we've been able to expose a
pretty complicated piece of technology
to someone that doesn't know how to code
to someone that knows how to talk to
these models in a highly instructive
highly clear way and that person is the
prompt engineer so really it's a
translator that's exactly what it is
you're translating between the machine
and the human seems like something I
could be pretty good at I think so too
but what's a good prompt and how do you
learn to write them well I went back to
school and by school I mean a corsera
class look at that 100 and 100 prompts
aren't just a oneoff that you give to
the large language model in his six week
prompt engineering for chat BT class Dr
Jules white a professor of computer
science at Vanderbilt University
teaches you how to structure sentences
to get the desired output from the bot
you seem bored by this browser there's
the Persona or role prompt for instance
act as an assistant helping a financial
analyst you're instructing the llm to
take on a Persona there's the new
information prompt this is where you
feed the model new data it might not
know about say here's the transcript
from the Microsoft earnings call please
summarize the mentions of Bing and and
you get a
summary he as Matrix app actually does
all of this it allows financial
institutions and other businesses to
upload or access huge data sets filings
earnings transcripts calls then it uses
AI to find answers so people don't have
to manually go through it all and that's
what SAA gave me as a prompt engineering
assignment so in this case let's say
that you are doing an analysis on
earnings call for a public company I did
a pretty good job at writing those
prompts but there was another part of
the job I wasn't prepared for coding in
some cases a prompt engineer may have to
code the queries into the tool itself so
he's clients can use them with a single
tap it was about that time that I knew
this probably wasn't my next
job plus I was a little worried about
how long this job might be a job which I
decided to bring up in my interview with
the CEO Joanna nice to meet you as these
models get better is prompt engineering
going to be necessary at the end of the
day you'll still need people to tell
them explicit
instructions even in programming where
machines are perfect at understanding
code there's still a job for people to
go back and
forth so what did I learn today well
getting a job as a prompt engineer is
harder than I thought still anyone who
wants to successfully work with AI tools
and elicit the best answers from them
really should learn some of these prompt
writing skills even if your next job
title isn't officially prompt
engineer Joanna enjoyed meeting you too
after some deliberation we will not be
continuing the hiring process here
wishing you the best in your
search yeah
rough